in this video we're going to talk about
the ten actual steps of glycolysis so
things I want you to keep in mind I want
you to pay attention to the names of the
enzymes that I write down and because
they generally make sense the name of
the enzyme will help you understand what
the enzyme does and what it what it acts
on in addition I want you to pay
attention from step to step what happens
to the molecule what part of the
molecule change that's also going to
help you remember what's going on in
addition I want you to note in
particular that there are some reactions
or that are written with a single arrow
and some that are written with a double
arrow the ones that are written with
single arrows can only the enzymes that
are have only a single arrow only
catalyze that forward reaction whereas
the enzymes with double arrows can
catalyze both the forward and the
reverse reaction so let's hop right to
it so as we said earlier in the previous
video glycolysis is the splitting of
sugar so we start off with glucose which
is a six carbon molecule so this is
glucose alpha D glucose to be specific
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
add an enzyme called hexa kinase now
what is hexokinase hexa or hex is the
root for six right so if we numbered
these carbons here must be carbon number
one two three four five and six and
kinase kinase is AD phosphate groups
from ATP right so we would expect
hexokinase to add a phosphate group to
the six HEC so the six carbons o H so
we're going to invest an ATP into this
reaction we're going to invest in ATP
because and then that that phosphate
from that ATP will be attached to the
six carbon so then the only difference
between this molecule is alpha D glucose
in this molecule here is that we've
attached the phosphate group to this
sixth carbon up here so the ATP becomes
an ADP so we've invested energy to start
off this process so hexokinase the
enzyme makes perfect sense
it's a kinase that adds a phosphate
group
be on the six-carbon and then we give
this molecule called glucose 6-phosphate
which is just glucose with a phosphate
group on it six carbon nothing too
complicated about that the next step is
catalyzed by phospho glucose isomerase
so it's an isomerase now isomers are
have the same molecular formula so we
know that that things going to be added
nothing is going to be added or removed
from this glucose 6-phosphate
so all we're going to do as i summarized
it we're going to move it around and
change it change the structure of it
it's an isomerase for a phospho glucose
well this glucose has a phosphate on it
so it's a phospho glucose isomerase it's
going to isomerize the phosphor glucose
specifically glucose 6-phosphate and we
end up getting this molecule here which
is fructose 6-phosphate which is still a
six carbon molecule and the carbon is or
the phosphate group is still in this six
carbon over here unless this is ice in
tonight's I'm erase nothing went into or
out of this reaction other than this
particular substrate cool
now the next step we're going to take
fructose 6-phosphate and we're going to
add the enzyme called phospho fruit
dough kinase 1 also known as p fk1 okay
so what is this phosphofructokinase
kinase it's going to add a phosphate
group from ATP okay where is it going to
add it on it's going to add it on to the
phospho fructose which is fructose the
phosphate on it so this enzyme will act
on the phosphor fructose which is
fructose 6-phosphate and it's going to
add a phosphate group from ATP onto the
one carbon that's why this one is here
so we're going to have an ATP invested
so that we add a phosphate group on to
this one carbon so the difference
between this molecule and this molecule
is that we've added
phosphate group here so what's left of
that ATP is an ADP so this is the second
time so here's our first investment of
energy here we just invested our in
energy the second time one thing I'd
like to note is that this particular
step is the first committed step of
glycolysis okay which I'll elaborate on
later first this is kind of small sorry
the first committed step of glycolysis
so this enzyme is going to be definitely
highly regulated again single arrow so
let's next okay ins we'll talk about
that later
but the whole idea is that this is the
first committed step of glycolysis so
it's going to be a highly regulated
enzyme and we'll see that later so what
we do we create here
well we added a phosphate group on to
this one carbon here onto this fruit to
the fridge oh six plus ready to create
this molecule here which is fructose 1 6
bisphosphate does that name make sense
well this is a fructose so that part
makes sense this phosphate has two
phosphates
where are the phosphates on the one
carbon and the sixth carbon so let me
number this really quickly too to make
sure that makes sense to you
1 2 3 4 5 6 carbons okay so fructose 1 6
bisphosphate again then it makes sense
so is that an enzyme name ok next step
the fourth step of glycolysis so at this
point what we're going to do is once
we've created for to us 1 6 bisphosphate
the thing this thing has committed to
glycolysis so what we're going to do
here is we're the enzyme aldolase I
don't have a fun or sort of meaningful
way to remember all the ways this one's
kind of just remember this one but this
one album releases the enzyme that
cleaves fructose Express this vest
bisphosphate the six carbon molecule
into two three carbon molecules so those
two three carbon molecules are
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate let's see if
these two names make sense
dihydroxyacetone so acetone is a ketone
right a ketone this is this here's a
carbonyl group with two car
neither side of it now this is a ch3 and
if this was a ch3 then it would just be
acetone but it is a dihydroxyacetone so
instead of a methyl group here we have a
hydroxyl group here a ch2oh okay but
says dihydroxy so we expect this to be a
ch2oh but it's not right instead it's a
phosphate so this is dihydroxyacetone
phosphate that's that's why this thing
is here
if this phosphate wasn't here it would
be dihydroxyacetone okay so again this
name makes sense if you think about it
this here is glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so we would expect to see a
glyceraldehyde and a phosphate on the
third carbon so the aldehyde would be
the number one carbon so this is ch oh
right that's the aldehyde up there
glyceraldehyde comes from sort of the
glycerol so we would expect that the
second carbon to be a C HOH and its last
one if it was glycerol it would be a
ch2oh but it's not ch2oh because the
phosphate groups on the third carbon so
we have a ch2 oh and the phosphate group
there okay so the two phosphate groups
from the for just one sec this phosphate
are here ones on this carbonate one or
ones on this mark molecule in this
molecule now what are we going to think
about something very important happens
here now between these two molecules
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate abbreviated
as g3p and I had actually acetone
phosphate abbreviate as DHAP only one of
them can go on further anyway calluses
that's glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so what we need to do is convert the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate into glycerol
3-phosphate so the enzyme that catalyzes
that reaction the fifth step I call is
this is called triose phosphate
isomerase
so triose phosphate isomerase triose
means three carbon sugar phosphate
means that that that three carbon sugar
has a phosphate group on it and it's
going to isomerize it which means it's
not going to add or remove anything it's
just going to move around the atoms that
are already there so this is the triose
phosphate is a three carbon molecule
three carbon molecule
with a phosphate group on it and we're
going to isomerize it we're just going
to turn it into GTP now after this fifth
step we have to 3G three P's
which is why I drew this pink bracket
here that means every single step that
happens here on out happens twice once
for each glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate so
everything here on out from here onward
everything happens two times okay so
once we have glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
what it's going to do it's going to
we're going to put an enzyme in here
called glyceraldehyde the sixth step is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate dehydrogenase
dehydrogenase okay if you recall I
mentioned that you would associate
excuse me
the term dehydrogenase with redox
reactions so something was oxidizing
something was reduced in this case
that's what we're gonna know and we
think about redox we want to think about
NAD+ NADH or FA DFID h2 in this case
we're gonna be thinking about NAD+ NADH
so what happened here well if we notice
on the third carbon here and the third
carbon here nothing change we saw that
CH 2 O and in the phosphate group
nothing changed in the third carbon the
second carbon C hoh-hoh nothing changed
there here with a CH oh right here now
we have a C oh oh po3 to negative okay
so what happened was this was
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate oxidized or
reduced well here it had this carbon was
bounded this carbon and then a single
bond to hydrogen and a double bond to
oxygen and just to sort of show you that
this would actually look like this right
it's missing aldehyde right it looks
like that so this carbon had a bond to
carbon a single bond to hydrogen and two
Austin now it still has that bond to
carbon that still has a double bond to
oxygen but now instead of a bond of
hydrogen has a lot of oxygen so
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
was oxidized to 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
ok so if this was oxidized something
must have been reduced well the thing
that was reduced was nad plus so we went
from an nad plus and created an NADH so
what really happened
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate was oxidized
nad plus was reduced to NADH in addition
notice that we added that phosphate
group right where did that phosphate
group come from that phosphate group
came from an inorganic phosphate from
the environment ok so that's going to be
noted as P sub I ok does this name make
sense 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate well the
phosphates are on the 1 carbon and the
the 3 carbon so 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
looks very much like with the the next
molecule which is actually 3
phosphoglycerate ok so the seventh step
is catalyzed by phosphoglycerate kinase
actually before I elaborate on this one
I wanted to make sure that this makes
sense glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase the dehydrogenase the
redox reaction occurred on the liver saw
right now though I had 3 phosphate in
case that wasn't perfectly clear
okay so phosphoglycerate kinase this
enzyme is kind of a little bit weird we
remember we associated kinases with
adding phosphates to things what
actually happens here
I remember if this is why the
introduction video took glycolysis is
important at this point we've already
created in invested two ATP's
so now we know we're not going to be
using up any more we should only be
making some so in this case what's going
to happen notice what happened to the
molecules carbons 2 & 3 CH o H CH 2 and
then this phosphate group over here it
looks identical carbons 2 & 3 the change
occur
first carbon here we have the phosphate
group here we no longer have it we just
have this carboxyl group so we lost that
phosphate group where did that phosphate
group go well it went onto an ADP to
create an ATP so here we made an ATP
okay so this phosphate comes over onto
this ADP to make ATP okay and then what
we're left with is this
3-phosphoglycerate so now I only have
one one phosphate group left here okay
now why is this called a kinase if we're
if why it is called phosphoglycerate
kinase why does that make sense well
this enzyme was probably named for the
reverse reaction think about the reverse
reaction going from 3 phosphoglycerate 2
1 3 bisphosphoglycerate you'd be taking
an ATP and going to adp and that
phosphate would be attached here to make
this right so this enzyme was likely
named for the reverse reaction maybe
because biochemists discovered that
reverse reaction before the forward
reaction okay so next up
step eight what happens here we're going
from 3 phosphoglycerate to
2-phosphoglycerate so the only thing
that happened was we went we took the
phosphate group from the third carbon
and moved it over to the second carbon
and then so the change occurred there so
we didn't add or remove any atoms so
this is kind of like an isomerase so
it's actually not an isomerase
unfortunately that's kind of confusing
but instead it's phosphoglycerate mutase
which i mean still make some sort of
sense we're mutating it whoops it looks
a little bit different but that's the
name of the enzyme as far as why I don't
know maybe scientists just wanted to
confuse students like us whatever it is
but the point is it is sort of an like
an isomerase and that all it does it
just it just moves the atoms around
doesn't actually add or remove anything
okay so then step 9 what we have is
we're going from 2-phosphoglycerate
to phosphoenolpyruvate so what's the
difference there the one carbon nothing
happened we selves a carb also grew up
there here well
we still have this phosphate group there
but we ended up forming this alkene here
so now the enzyme that catalyzes this
step is called enol ace if you recall
from organic chemistry an enol was
essentially an alkene right next to a
hydroxyl group so here what we're doing
we're making phosphoenolpyruvate notice
how this looks this is an alkene next to
what would be a hydroxyl group input but
instead this is a phosphate this is an
alkene and this was an H here that would
be an email this is a phosphoenol so
there's the alkene and then this
phosphate group instead of the hydroxyl
group how did that form well
what ends up happening is we lose this
hydrogen and this off this hydroxyl
group we lose them both in the form of
water to form that double bond there
okay so we lose this H we lose this o H
and then we form a double bond there and
then we're left with phosphoenolpyruvate
which is a very high-energy molecule and
when it's converted into pyruvate via
the enzyme pyruvate kinase oh goodness
I'm moving on to this and I haven't
mentioned Dena lace in a lace makes
sense right it's the it's the enzyme
that forms this phosphoenol okay
possibly on a part of a then is
converted into pyruvate so what sitting
these two molecules well the carboxyl
group stays the same the methyl group
that we formed the methyl group right we
can get rid of this alkene we get rid of
this phosphate group where does that
phosphate group go actually before I
even mention anything at this point
how many ATP's have we invested well we
invested two up here let me scroll back
up for a second we invested two invested
one here and one here
how many ATP's have we made so far one
no we've made to write this each
reaction here creates one ATP but recall
that we have a blister aldehyde three
phosphate there's two of them right so
each reaction in that app that this
happens twice so we've created at this
point two ATP and we've created two NADH
'iz so at the at step seven we've all
paid back our debt okay so now here this
is the reaction that was the final
reaction so we're actually going to net
our ATP here so this phosphate where
does it go it gets tacked on to ADP to
make an ATP okay notice have a little
green star here to indicate that this
enzyme Alice directly regulated so here
we have pyruvate we specifically have
two pyruvates okay so if you recall the
introduction video mentioned the
products so hopefully this all makes
sense now how we have you got all that
so let's do a quick little recap of what
we covered the steps above that had a
little green star next to them are the
allosteric a regulated enzymes in the
next video we'll be covering that as far
as the recap the first reaction was the
first energy investment you scroll back
up pause the video and and check that
out
the third and the third step was a
second energy investment and that was
the first committee step catalyzed by
phosphofructokinase one that if it's the
first committee step we know that that
first committed step must be out excuse
me allosteric be regulated hmm at steps
four and five right we have to realize
that only g3p goes right at 3 phosphate
can go on and glycolysis and continue so
everything made after that point is is
made twice because there are two g3ps
the sixth step is a redox reaction right
which is we know that because the DI
drogyn ace and of course that's when the
coenzyme nad plus comes into play to be
created into NADH the seventh step is
with the first substrate level
phosphorylation so substrate level
phosphorylation is just this idea that
here we are taking this enzyme this
phosphoglycerate kinase is acting on
this substrate 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
and it's taking that phosphate off of
there and adding it on to ADP to make
ATP so that's what's that's what's
substrate level phosphorylation is just
taking a phosphate off of a substrate
and tacking it on to ADP to make ATP
okay so that's the first substrate
phosphorylation in that seventh step at
that point we've paid back our two ATP's
right because that reaction happens
twice and the tenth step is our second
substrate level phosphorylation and
that's of course when we net of the two
ATP so
all we created four ATP's but we net two
of them because two of them have to pay
back our initial debt from these two
energy investments in addition it just
has a key note something I'd like to
mention here is that the tenth step
going from fossil you know pyruvate to
pyruvate there's a lot of energy
released and that energy release powers
the production of ATP but there's enough
there's enough energy release to power
the production of two ATP's but only one
is made which is interesting that's a
little bit inefficient in terms of
energy why doesn't that reaction power
the production of two ATP's it would be
ideal if it could so it's interesting
maybe if you know you become a research
but a biochemistry researcher and if you
can or a biochemical research or
whatever or a bioengineer who knows if
you can somehow engineer a way to make
it so that that particular reaction
produces two ATP's instead of one ATP I
mean that'd be pretty awesome that would
just make biological organisms much more
energy efficient so that'd be cool
that'd be pretty interesting so that's
about it thanks for watching the video
guys